qui a poussé sur les routes des millions
d'ukrainiens elles sont déjà plus de
trois millions de réfugiés avoir quitté
l'ukraine près de la moitié sont
aujourd'hui des enfants de très nombreux
autres civils ont été déplacés aussi par
cette guerre la plupart sont allés se
réfugier dans l'ouest du pays on va
retrouver tout de suite en direct de
tiene d'ci anastasia pérouse bonjour et
merci tout d'abord d'être avec nous nous
accorder ce moment avant la guerre vous
vous travaillez en tant que traductrice
et et médiatrice culturelle pour les
filmer et festivals de cinéma vous
habitiez kiev au moment de l'invasion
russe votre compagnon belge vous rendez
visite après les premiers bombardements
et des heures difficiles dans les abris
vous avez décidé avec toute votre
famille de quitter la capitale en train
pour vous réfugiez non loin de la
frontière avec la roumanie c'est une
zone qui était jusque là épargnée vous
étiez censé intervenir hier sur notre
antenne mais les sirènes et les alertes
en ont décidé autrement la première
question évidemment qu'on a envie de
vous poser c'est comment allez vous
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que la situation est en train
de se compliquer là vous vous trouvez
aujourd'hui
bonjour lui la situation se complique
dans la mesure où il ya des explosions
des attaques sur la ville à côté dans
les régions à côté et c'est triste à
dire mais je dis pas que c'est là la
question du temps quelqu'un parce qu'ils
vont arriver jusqu'à ici parce que ce
qu'on voit c'est que les russes n'ont
pas beaucoup de succès sur terre donc ce
qu'il essaie de faire c'est de faire
peur à toute la population et la façon
la plus simple de faire part à la
population c'est de lancer les missiles
aux roses et les civils en pilonnant des
zones d'habitation on l'a déjà vu en
trois semaines en trois semaines
deux guerres un mot peut-être de kiev
vous êtes résolu assez vite finalement
acquitté votre vie là bas est ce que
vous allez malgré tout des nouvelles de
proches restés sur place elle nombreux
habitants qui sont quand même restés
dans la capitale ukrainienne
on nous dit qu'il ya une la moitié de la
population qui est reste qu'hier j'ai
beaucoup d'amis j'ai pas de famille qui
est restée mais j'ai beaucoup d'amis
c'est difficile c'est beaucoup de temps
passé les nuits et dans les abris dans
les sous sols non excusez moi
mais tout le monde de reste assez
positif et très résolus donc l'esprit de
combat à l'esprit de victoire de lutte
très très sensible
sur le cac et on l'entend dans
absolument tous les témoignages vous
laissez pas vraiment la place aux
émotions voulez vous l'expliquer assez
bien à nos confrères de france inter il
ya quelques jours encore vous avez le
sentiment que votre cerveau à fait
commun un reset et qu'il laissait pas
passer les émotions la seule émotion que
vous ressentez et que vous n'aviez
jamais ressenti à ce point c'est la
haine la haine envers le régime russe
aujourd'hui
mais c'est tout à fait vrai bah
ya vu des photos d'une station de métro
à kiev qui est à côté de ma maison qui
qui a été touchée donc une explosion a
eu lieu dans un bâtiment à côté de chez
moi les bâtiments de la rue à côté sont
détruits et seas
bizarrement je pense que c'est notre
système de protection même s'il ya des
périodes où c'est dur on peut pleurer on
se sent très malheureux je pense que le
sentiment qui prévalent
c'est tout le monde
était alors la liaison est un peu
compliqué on va évidemment rester avec
vous vous avez fait votre famille votre
compagnon belge votre soeur également
vous expliquez que qu'elle pleurait
chaque jour que vous vous réagissiez
différemment on parlait de ses émotions
comment est ce que vous comptez
aujourd'hui aider votre votre pays vous
dites on a on a préféré quitter kiev
pour être un peu plus utile ailleurs
pour lutter notamment contre la la
désinformation votre quotidien ils se
résument en quoi aujourd'hui
pour moi je suis traductrice la base
donc je traduis pas mal de choses pour
les différents projets notamment il ya
beaucoup de cinéastes qui font des
vidéos qui enregistre ce qui se passe
pour plus tard pour faire des films pour
un
collecter miage pour montrer au monde
d'accord je travaille à des cinéastes
qui font ça qui font des capsules vidéo
rage d'être admis je fais de ce titre il
ya aussi un groupe de travail des
traducteurs qui collabore avec le bureau
du président
il ya beaucoup de groupes comme ça des
bénévoles si vous voulez qu'ils sont
prêts à agir et puis ma soeur elle est
un peu plus
elle est un peu plus à l'aise avec les
ordinateurs et est là elle
participe au groupe de travail avec des
bénévoles qui qui font des choses un peu
plus complexes par exemple les attaques
sur les sites des médias de propagande
russe ou l'envoi des mails en masse aux
russes donc il ya beaucoup de façons du
de participer à ce combat numérique le
gouvernement ukrainien d'ailleurs à
solliciter l'ensemble des ukrainiens
leur demandant d'ouvrir des comptes sur
les réseaux sociaux pour ceux qui n'en
avaient pas déjà encore pour montrer
la réalité de cette guerre est-ce que
vous avez vous avez probablement les
retours de cette journaliste russe qui
est intervenu sur la première chaîne de
télévision russe qui a depuis été
condamné à payer une amende mais qui va
avoir un procès et qui encourent 15 ans
de prison pour avoir dénoncé la
propagande du régime
j'imagine que ça vous rassure de savoir
qu'une partie des russes même s'ils sont
silencieux tente aujourd'hui de deux
communiqués de s'exprimer malgré les
risques
alors je sais pas si ça vous quels sont
les actualités qui arrive jusqu'aux
france maintenant il craint donné assez
sceptique envers cette journaliste parce
que il ya plusieurs raisons pour l'être
d'abord on croit pas qu'il ya des
émissions en live sur les chaînes de
propagande les chefs d'état russe donc
il ya beaucoup de choses qu'ils ont dit
que c'était en fait
[Musique]
mise en scène si vous voulez que c'était
préparé et
puis cette journaliste a bien un
discours qui était enregistrée avant
cette action est dans ce discours elle
utilise les mêmes schémas et les mêmes
phrases les mêmes péchés de la
propagande russe comme quoi on était les
nations frères des peuples frères elle
utilisait les phrases tout à fait bien
fait qu'ils sont et répéter encore et
encore et encore sur les chaînes de télé
russe et après la montre qu'il a reçu
ses trente mille roubles c'est environ
200 300 euros euro-dollar et c'est
vraiment ridicule si vous comparez avec
les amendes que les autres reçoivent
elles devaient pas être dans un procès
prochainement elle encourt 15 ans de
prison je vous le confirme si vous
pouviez vous adresser à la à la russie
qu'est ce que vous diriez aux russes
aujourd'hui qui qu'est ce que vous
diriez vous aux russes s'il avait les
moyens de vous entendre aujourd'hui
bac ils sont tous capables coupable de
ce qui se passait nous craignent c'est
pas poutine qui appuie sur les boutons
c'est pa pou ti ne sais pas cent
cinquante mille poutine qui sont
rassemblés autour des frontières à une
chrétienne c'est pas poutine
personnellement qui tue les enfants en
ukraine c'est pas pour détecter des
scénarios des fins de propagande ruse et
cetera et cetera donc je pense que tout
le monde qui vit là bas qui est
silencieux qui payent des amendes qui
raconte des salades sur les peuples
frères
ukraine en russie
beaucoup de moyens de recevoir des
informations là maintenant bien sûr que
facebook instagram tout est bloqué en
russie mais ce n'était pas le cas
jusqu'à présent il ya beaucoup de
sources d'information et s'ils sont dans
le déni c'est parce qu'ils veulent être
dans le déni c'est parce qu'ils peuvent
ils veulent pas
comprendre savoir et se sentir impliqué
dans tout ce qui se passe merci beaucoup
anastasia à péronnas si je vous résume
vous dénoncez une forme de
responsabilité collective aujourd'hui
merci à vous c'est la fin